>>> WE WANT YOU TO MEET TWO
BLACK RADIO HOSTS IN ARIZONA
WHO ARE TAKING THE ACTION TO
STOP THE PHRASE WHITE LIVES
MATTER WHICH IS OFTEN USED BY
WHITE SUPREMIST GROUPS AND HAS
BEEN CALLED A RACIST RESPONSE
TO THE BLACK LIVES MATTER
MOVEMENT.
THE ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE
CALLED IT A HATE SLOGAN AND IT
MOST RECENTLY POPPED UP BY T-
SHIRTS DESIGNED BY KANYE WEST.
RAMSES JA AND QUINTON WARD HOST
THE NATIONALLY BROADCAST RADIO
SHOW.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
RAMSES, WHAT DO YOU PLAN TO DO
WITH THIS TRADEMARK OF WHITE
LIVES MATTER?
>> WELL, AT PRESENT WE PLAN TO
DO NOTHING.
NOTHING IS PLENTY AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE.
WE HAVE LAWYERS ADVISING US ON
HOW TO BEST PROTECT THE
TRADEMARK.
SO IT WILL NOT BE USED TO HURT,
HARM, TRIGGER ANY PEOPLE AND AS
LONG AS WE ARE THE PEOPLE IN
THE POSITION TO DECIDE HOW IT
IS USED IN COMMERCE, WE WILL DO
OUR BEST TO MINIMIZE THE EFFECT
THAT IT MAY HAVE ON PEOPLE,
ESPECIALLY BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE.
>> QUINTON, JUST EXPLAIN THAT.
YOU BY DESIGN DON'T PLAN TO DO
ANYTHING WITH IT AND THAT MEANS
NOBODY ELSE CAN.
IS THAT THE POINT?
>> AT PRESENT, YES.
AND JUST TO MAKE IT CLEAR, WE
DIDN'T PURCHASE OR PURSUE THE
MARK.
IT WAS ACTUALLY ASSIGNED TO US
BY ONE OF OUR LISTENERS.
>> SO ONE OF YOUR LISTENERS GOT
THE TRADEMARK AND ANONYMOUSLY,
AS I UNDERSTAND IT, GAVE IT TO
YOU.
>> YES.
>> WHAT I THINK IS SO
FASCINATING ABOUT THIS,
GENTLEMEN, IS A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T REALIZE YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT TO TRADEMARK CERTAIN
PHRASES IN CONNECTION WITH A
PRODUCT IN PARTICULAR AND WHAT
WAS SO INGENIOUS I THINK ABOUT
THIS ORIGINAL NOTION WAS THAT
IF YOU TRADEMARK SOMETHING,
THEN OBVIOUSLY IT CANNOT BE
USED BY OTHER PEOPLE.
YOU'VE GOT TO OBVIOUSLY POLICE
THAT AND MAKE SURE IT'S NOT
BEING USED, BUT IT WAS THE GOAL
THAT I THINK IS SO FASCINATING
THAT EVERYONE NEEDS TO KNOW
ABOUT BECAUSE YOU WERE A LITTLE
BIT CONCERNED ABOUT BEING ABLE
TO AND OTHERS BEING ABLE TO
EXPLOIT THIS PARTICULAR PHRASE,
BEING ABLE TO PROFIT OFF OF IT
AND THAT WAS REALLY THE DRIVING
FORCE OF WHY IT WAS ASSIGNED,
WHY IT WAS GIVEN IN THE FIRST
PLACE, BUT SPEAK TO US A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT
TO YOU, TO HAVE THIS NOT BE
ABLE TO BE PROFITED OFF OF IN
THE TIME WE'RE IN.
>> YEAH.
I'LL GO FIRST.
SO IT'S REALLY ABOUT
CONTROLLING WHO CAN PROFIT FROM
IT.
AGAIN, WE HAVE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL ABOUT THE LANGUAGE HERE
BECAUSE TRADEMARKS ARE A LITTLE
TRICKY, BUT IN TERMS OF HOW IT
FEELS TO BE AT THE HELM OF THIS
MOMENT, I CAN SAY THAT IT FEELS
GOOD TO SEE PEOPLE'S REACTION
TO IT, TO SEE PEOPLE FEEL LIKE
THEY HAVE A REASON TO SMILE.
THE PAST FEW WEEKS HAVE BEEN
HEAVY FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE, BEEN
TRIGGERING FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE.
SO THAT FEELS GOOD AND AGAIN,
WE'LL DO RIGHT BY FOLKS.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> I'M SORRY.
>> NO.
GO AHEAD.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY SEEING
THAT PHRASE ON A T-SHIRT,
IMAGINE I'D LIKE TO PAINT A
PICTURE SITTING ON YOUR PORCH
AND SOMEONE WALKING UP TO YOUR
HOME WITH A CONFEDERATE FLAG
OVER ONE SHOULDER, A TRUMP FLAG
OVER THE OTHER SHOULDER, MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN HAT ON, A T-
SHIRT THAT SAYS WHITE LIVES
MATTER ON THE FRONT AND THAT
SAYS SLAVERY WAS A CHOICE ON
THE BACK AND IMAGINE THAT
PERSON HOLDING A BULLHORN AND
SAYING THROUGH IT GEORGE FLOYD
WAS NOT KILLED BY POLICE, BUT
HE DIED FROM A DRUG OVERDOSE.
IMAGINE HOW THAT WOULD MAKE YOU
FEEL AND THEN EXPLAIN TO ME WHY
I SHOULD FEEL DIFFERENT BECAUSE
THE PERSON WEARING ALL OF THAT
STUFF IS A CREATIVE GENIUS.
>> THE PICTURE YOU PAINT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT, ALSO THE IDEA
OF WHY AND TO THAT POINT SO
MANY PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
COMPARTMENTALIZE BASED ON WHAT
YOU'VE SAID, THE IDEA IT'S OKAY
AS LONG AS IT'S SOMEBODY WHO IS
NOT WHITE WHO IS WEARING IT OR
SOMEBODY IS ABLE TO BE
APPLAUDED FOR A VERY DIFFERENT
ASPECT OF HIS LIFE.
THAT'S MOST IMPORTANT TO YOU,
TO BE ABLE TO REMOVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CAPITALIZE ON
THAT.
>> EXACTLY.
YOU KNOW, AGAIN, WE FEEL LIKE,
IN FACT, IT'S WELL DOCUMENTED
THAT THE TERM WHITE LIVES
MATTER ROSE UP IN OPPOSITION TO
THE AFFIRMATION THAT BLACK
LIVES MATTER.
IT HAS NEVER BEEN IN QUESTION
WHETHER OR NOT WHITE LIVES HAVE
MATTERED IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT'S A GIVEN.
WE KNOW THAT.
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT.
WE FELT IN OUR COMMUNITY THAT
WE NEEDED TO SAY BLACK LIVES
MATTER, PARTICULARLY AFTER THE
DEATH OF TRAYVON MARTIN AND SO
AGAIN, THESE OTHER MATTER TERMS
AND PHRASES HAVE ROSE UP IN
OPPOSITION TO THAT TO WEAKEN
THE MESSAGE, TO DILUTE THE
MOVEMENT AND TO JUST BE
CONTRADICTORY IN NATURE TO GIVE
OTHER PEOPLE TALKING POINTS IN
A CONVERSATION WHEN THE PHRASE
WAS ORIGINALLY INTENDED TO
AFFIRM OUR LIVES HAVING VALUE.
AND SO AGAIN, BEING AT THE HELM
OF SOMETHING LIKE THIS, BEING
ABLE TO BE THE DECIDER FEELS
VERY IMPORTANT.
IT'S AMONG THE HEAVIEST THINGS
THAT WE'VE HAD TO DO AS RADIO
HOSTS OF A SOCIAL JUSTICE RADIO
SHOW THAT WE DO BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE IN THE GREATER GOOD OF
ALL PEOPLE.
WE BELIEVE THAT WE CAN COME
TOGETHER ACROSS CULTURAL LINES,
RACIAL LINES, TRIBAL LINES AND
HAVE CONVERSATIONS AND REALLY
GROW.
THAT'S AT THE HEART OF
EVERYTHING WE'RE TRYING TO DO
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE
MANEUVER THAT -- OR RATHER THE
POSITION THAT WE'VE TAKEN WILL
YIELD THE MOST GOOD FOR THE
MOST PEOPLE.
THAT'S OUR HOPE AND WE'RE GOING
TO DO OUR BEST TO DO RIGHT BY
EVERYONE.
>> QUINTON, VERY QUICKLY, THAT
PICTURE THAT YOU PAINTED OF,
YOU KNOW, HOW SORT OF
OFFPUTTING IT WAS, WHAT'S YOUR
MESSAGE TO KANYE WEST WITH OR
YE AS HE GOES BY AND CANDACE
OWENS WHO WERE THE ONES WHO
WORE THOSE T-SHIRTS SO
PUBLICLY?
>> I'M ACTUALLY GLAD YOU ASKED
THAT QUESTION BECAUSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO SEE THE HEADLINE IN
THE PICTURE, ASSUME THAT WE
HAVE SOME PERSONAL BEEF OR
PROBLEM WITH KANYE WEST OR YE
AND WE DON'T, RIGHT?
WE JUST DON'T LIKE THE HURT
THAT COMES FROM THAT MESSAGE,
WHETHER IT BE INTENTIONAL OR
NOT, AND WE'RE JUST TRYING TO
LIMIT AS MUCH AS WE CAN THE
AMOUNT